[Musik]
der hat zehn sie
überall auf der welt
und gleicht
rund um die uhr
filmen kameras
packende
extrem ruhig bleibt ruhig
furchterregende
naturphänomene was sollen wir tun guck
dir das an man ist wie gelähmt
es gibt kein entkommen
das ist reality tv sie glauben sie
kennen das wetter diese experten
erklären was wirklich passiert das
wasser fließt in den wirbel mit
den spektakulärsten wetter videos der
welt
wenn sich ein sturm zusammenbraut gehen
die meisten in deckung
aber reporter draußen an der wetterfront
riskieren alles
sieh dir das an
[Musik]
september 2004 hurrikan frances trifft
mit windgeschwindigkeiten von rund 170
kilometer pro stunde auf die küste von
florida in west palm beach berichten
michael rooker live
bist du bereit für das auge des sturms
kumpel rat
spitzen reporter stemmen sich gemeinsam
gegen den sturm mike seidel und aloqa
umklammern sich fest damit die bühne sie
nicht wegfegen
wir waren beim yachthafen zwei boote
sind schon weg ein paar treiben den
inter coastal kanal herunter echt übel
meint berichtete live und während seiner
reportage legte der wind sichtbar zu
das sind gut 100 kilometer pro stunde
locker
hurricanes gehören zu den verheerendsten
störungen der welt und der hier liegt
gerade erst los
man kämpft um sein gleich gericht und
muss parallel berichten sehen wären die
gedanken ums nackte überleben kreisen
versuchst irgend etwas schlaues zu sagen
gehen wir lieber entdeckungen machen
schluss
wir haben uns einen job ausgesucht weil
jemand sich den elementen aussetzen muss
wenn so richtig abgeht
rund 320 kilometer weiter die küste hoch
new smyrna beach steht stefanie abrams
auf einem dach und berichtet über
denselben sturm
ich war noch nicht dran dabei unser team
meldet von dort werden von 120
kilometern habe ich keinen zweifel wir
können
es dauerte ewig der hurrikan die küste
erreicht aber als er dann kam
das dach des wohnblocks auf dem wir
stehen wird förmlich wenn ihr mit
überall liegen trümmerteile herum eine
kurze sicht etwas davon einzufahren
jetzt nähert sich das auge des hurrikans
das fast windstille zentrum ist vom
sogenannten augen wall umgeben einem
ring aus mehreren gewittern hier tobt
der sturm am heftigsten
aus dem augenwinkel sehe ich dann dieses
metallteil direkt auf uns zu fliegen
sagt pass auf 8
als hurrikan jäger fürchte ich mich am
meisten vor fliegenden blechteilen das
zeug ist leicht superschnell im wind und
wenn es dich mit voller wucht trifft
kann es die den kopf abreißen
da ist ihr egal ob du auf sendung ist es
wird immer schlimmer ich gehe in deckung
hat auf dem das dach hier wird gerade
zerlegt da kommt schon wieder warten
das ist reality tv du bist live dabei
sie ist jede reaktion die kameraleute
werden hektisch für user laufen ins bild
solche wetter reportagen verlangen dir
alles ab
die reporter überstehen hurrikan francis
unverletzt aber der sturm tötet in den
usa sieben menschen und verursacht
schäden in höhe von rund neun milliarden
dollar wegen dieser tragischen
verwüstungen sperrt der welt
meteorologen verband den namen francis
für künftige hurricanes
aber mit welchen methoden werden so
verheerende stürme erforscht
2014 riefen die nasa und die japanische
weltraumbehörde eine globale mission ins
leben gpm ist ein niederschlags mess
system aus mehreren satelliten die
weltweit regen und schneefälle messen
mittels mikrowellen und radartechnik
werden 3d karten des stroms erstellt um
die regenmenge zu bestimmen
und wenn man in einen hurrikan gerät wie
viel wind kann ein menschlicher körper
aushalten
das hier ist kein wrestler im kostüm
sondern jim carrey vom us- weather
channel getestet welche windstärke ein
mensch ertragen kann auf einer skala bis
10 können hier sturmböen von bis zu 300
kilometer pro stunde erzeugt werden
der stärkste mit dem ich bisher
ausgesetzt war lag zwischen 130 und 150
kilometern pro stunde ab da kannst du
dem wind ohne so ein geschirr nicht mehr
standhalten
das experiment beginnt bei einer
windstärke die die meisten von uns nie
selbst erleben werden
das entspricht jetzt an dem heftigen
tropensturm von um die 100
stundenkilometer
das ist fast schon hurrikan-stärke mein
haut fängt an zu vibrieren
das tut sicher wenn die haut so flattert
ein unangenehmes gefühl jetzt stehen wir
mitten in einem hurrikan mal sehen was
passiert auf geht's
ich dachte ein paar mal meine füße eben
ab und ich lande mit dem gesicht von
das ist jetzt der stärkste hinsicht
tatsächlich schon erlebt habe um die 140
stundenkilometer
jetzt schon 160
mehr als 160 hält man nicht aus ohne
sich anzuschnallen und selbst dann muss
man sich echt festklammern jetzt bläst
ihm ein hurrikan der höchsten kategorie
fünf auf der saffir simpson skala ins
gesicht
man kann kaum mehr atmen weil der wind
einem mit voller wucht auf den mund und
wie die haut flattert so sollte an
geschichte niemals aussehen ich nicht
[Musik]
ich bin baff dass ich bis 255
rausgegangen bin ich wollte sogar 280
aber sie haben mich gestoppt
das entspricht kategorie 5 v geschafft
ich würde sofort wieder machen nächstes
mal bis 280 mein ziel fürs frühjahr
wissen sie wie stark stürme werden
können
der weltrekord liegt derzeit bei rund
500 kilometer pro stunde er wurde 1999
per doppler radar in einem tornado nach
oklahoma city gemessen
[Musik]
bei naturgewalten heißt es oft lieber
abstand halten ob im gewitter sehen sie
das
das war direkt über mir oder schneesturm
oh
ja ja ja wir haben es nicht geschafft
sonst wird man eiskalt erwischt
oh
mann da kommt was runter habt ihr das
gesehen oktober 2014 elf markov
berichtet als reporter für den us-
weather channel live von einem dach in
nashville tennessee über gewitter
plötzlich wird er selbst zur story
die warnung vor schweren gewittern gilt
weiter außerdem könnte es fremdartige
überschwemmungen geben und was
alle im kontrollraum sprang auf wie man
dave macht es oder wie kommst du siehst
den blitz und dann boom der donner und
er sagt sofort wir müssen weg was auch
goldrichtig ist mit einem blitz ist
nicht zu spaßen
das war direkt über mir
wir sind gleich wieder für euch da
sein gesicht sprach bände
das wird mir jetzt zu gefährlich als ich
mit gleich nach dem donner umdrehte sah
ich wie sich der lichtbogen direkt vor
meinen augen in luft auflöste
wie nah hat der blitz eingeschlagen
um die entfernung zu bestimmen kann man
die sekunden zwischen blitz und donner
zellen der schall bewegt sich mit rund
340 meter pro sekunde durch die luft
drei sekunden entsprechend demnach rund
einen kilometer
wenn wir also hier die zeit zwischen
blitz und donner messen könnte es flut
artige überschreiten
1,4 sekunden also schlug der blitz knapp
500 meter neben dave 1 ich gebe zu
wenig zeit liegt bist du viel zu nahe
[Musik]
pro sekunde treffen 100 blitze die erde
in deutschland schlägt pro jahr mehr als
500.000 mal der blitz ein
[Musik]
jeden tag gibt es in der erdatmosphäre
rund 2000 gewitter aber
nur ganz selten blitzt und donnert es
während eines schneesturms eine seltsame
und heftige mischung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hört euch das an verdammt
unglaublich
februar 2011 jim carrey berichtet live
über den drittgrößten schneesturm den
chicago bis dahin erlebt hat über einen
halben meter hoch liegt der schnee in
der stadt als plötzlich ein schnee
gewitter los geht
du heilige scheiße
erst kommt ein weißer blitz dann hörst
du den donner aber ohne dieses typische
krachen es ist eher ein grollen das vom
schneefall gedämpft wird eine
einzigartige erfahrung oh
mein gott
in chicago dauerte dieses vergnügen 45
minuten
wenn sich so etwas genau über die
entlädt ist das kann schön aufregend
genau wie bei einem regenschauer kann
die kombination von warmen boden
temperaturen und kühleren luftschichten
zu einer instabilen wetterlage und
schließlich zu blitz und donner führen
doch bei einem schneesturm ist der boden
eigentlich nicht warm genug für diesen
effekt
gott
[Musik]
2015 gerät jim carrey wieder in ein
schnee gewitter boston im us-bundesstaat
massachusetts wird im februar von einem
heftigen blizzard nach dem anderen
getroffen canori berichtet über den
wintersturm neptun und verwandelt sich
immer mehr in einen schneemann neben
mehr als 40 zentimeter neuschnee hat
dieser störung für einen schnee gewitter
fan wie ihn aber noch mehr zu bieten
oh
ja ja ja ja das haben wir im kasten
wahnsinn
was das fünfte mal dass ich so was vor
der kamera lebt habe nicht nur auf der
straße sondern live drauf ich habe nicht
fast durchgedreht
[Musik]
wer will nochmal zwei zum preis von
einem
flippt hier wohl so aus weil er solche
bilder noch nicht in seinem schnee
gewitter repertoire hatte
[Musik]
der blanke wahnsinn
da noch einer ich als nicht aus
jims begeisterungsstürme für schnee
gewitter sind zu einem hit im internet
geworden
das war gerade ein donner
selbst der 500 millionen jackpot im
lotto ist nichts gegen das hier man das
macht jetzt schon vier blitzeinschläge
gleich wird ein verheerender tornado zum
medienstar
unglaublich seht euch das an wir können
direkt hinein sehen
und ein monstersturm zerstört eine ganze
stadt
wenn du siehst wie jemand der sich sonst
immer unter kontrolle hat die fassung
verliert dann berührt dass die leute
juni 2009 mike bettes berichtet über das
tornado forschungsprojekt vortex 2 es
nutzt nicht nur modernste technik
sondern auch live reportagen
2 ist das größte bisher dagewesene
tornado feldexperiment die
wissenschaftler sammeln alle möglichen
daten zu tornados sie wollen
herausfinden wie sie entstehen und wie
man ein frühwarnsystem aufbauen kann
sieht aus als ob mehrere trichter den
boden berühren
jetzt wird es ernst das forschungsteam
bekommt gleich seinen ersten tornado vor
die linse
einem tornado der sich so perfekt
aufbaut erwischt man nicht offen und
dazu noch aus einer sicheren distanz die
tornado geburt auf video wird später zum
lieblings studienobjekt für forscher und
leihen
an dieser stelle ist der trichter so nah
am boden
ich war als live kommentator im studio
dass wir die bilder gleichzeitig vor ort
und den studio genau analysieren konnten
war fantastisch
es war als ob wir gemeinsam geschichte
schreiben
in motion county wyoming wurde gerade
eine tornado warnung herausgegeben die
gegend ist kaum besiedelt hier sehen wir
wie ein bilderbuch tornado über das land
fegt es sieht so aus als ob er nach
süden dreht
ein trichter ist uns ziemlich nah
gekommen sah fast so aus als würde sich
vor uns verneigen wir konnten direkt in
sein hohes inneres schauen
ich glaube wir waren von anfang an dabei
von der entstehung der trichter wolke
über den schmalen rüssels bis zum
breiten tornado wir können sogar direkt
ins innere des tornados schauen doktor
forbes sehen sie nur
wenn sie genau hinschauen erkennen sie
in der mitte eine dünne bahn das ist das
zentrum des tornados vor ein teil der
luft hoch steigt
normalerweise deckt eine dichte
wolkendecke den tornado oben ab so dass
ein blick ins innere nicht möglich ist
aber hier drückt ein abwind gegen den
tornado der wirbel biegt sich und
gewährt diesen seltenen einblick
ich habe hoch gekocht und konnte es kaum
fassen so etwas hatte ich noch nie
gesehen das war unglaublich
wir sind dem tornado zwölf kilometer
gefolgt und haben die 25 minuten lang
berichtet für das vortex zwei projekt
war das ein großer erfolg
den forschern bescherte das video eine
regelrechte datenflut die informationen
über diesen tornado werden sie noch über
viele jahre beschäftigen
bei dem twister in wyoming wurde niemand
verletzt ein anderes unwetter zwei jahre
später in joplin missouri sollte leider
anders verlaufen mike batt ist und sein
team kommen zum drehen in einer stadt
durch die nur wenige minuten zuvor ein
katastrophaler tornado gefegt ist
der sturm hatte sich schnell aufgebaut
von einem normalen sommergewitter zu
einer riesigen super zelle die einen ein
kilometer breiten tornado erzeugte so
heftig wie einer nur sein kann
höhe von 320 kilometer pro stunde haben
eine schneise durch die stadt geschlagen
sehen sie sich um alles ist völlig
zerstört familien haben ihr zuhause
verloren ihr leben steht jetzt kopf
ich mag die bilder nicht sehen da kommen
zu viele erinnerungen hoch es war ein
schwarzer tag
die leute suchen nach ihren angehörigen
wenn ich mich umschaue erinnert mich das
alles hier an das was wir letzten monat
entschuldigung
in tuscaloosa gesehen habe
und es gab tote
ich habe es in meiner reportage nicht
gesagt aber ich dachte wir könnten
hunderte ums leben gekommen sein das hat
mir die kehle zuschnürt
die einsam
[Musik]
wenn man sieht wie jemand der sonst
total kontrolliert ist die fassung
verliert berührt dass die leute
ich habe schon über viele katastrophen
berichtet in diesem geschäft lernst du
so etwas nicht an die clan kommen zu
lassen aber in dem moment konnte ich das
einfach nicht
der tornado in joplin dauert keine 40
minuten aber er zerstört fast ein
drittel der stadt und tötet etwa 160
menschen es ist der verheerendste
tornado in den usa seit ende der 40er
jahre
das hier war mal ein wohngebiet jetzt
laufen die menschen völlig aufgelöst
herum haben sich schon jemanden wieder
gefunden ihre nachbarn nein
ich finde keine handschuhe ich habe in
meiner garage nachgeschaut aber da sind
keine das war bei weitem das schlimmste
was ich je gesehen habe nicht nur in
meinem beruf sondern überhaupt so etwas
trauriges war mir noch nie untergekommen
80 prozent der tornados weltweit treffen
die usa und kanada aber sie können sich
auf jedem kontinent bilden ausgenommen
der antarktis dort gibt es nicht
genügend feucht-warme luft um das
instabile wetter zu schaffen dass solch
ein sturm braucht
april 2014
ein massiver tornado fegt über tupelo
mississippi hinweg
im studio des senders double you tv news
erfährt der wetterbericht von matt
laufen plötzlich einen ganz besonderen
realitätscheck
zudem wird bestätigt dass der tornado
den boden berührt hat moment
unsere stromversorgung hat was
abbekommen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
wir noch auf sendung sind
der meteorologe beobachtet wie der
tornado sich dem studio nähert und ist
sich da nicht sicher ob sein signal
überhaupt noch ausgeht
wir sind noch auf sendung dies ist eine
tornado warnung für lee county
das ist verrückt und schrecklich
zugleich versucht seinen job zu machen
damit auch jeder gewarnt ist und sich in
sicherheit bringen kann
genau jetzt fliegt ein tornado durch die
stadt tupelo es besteht lebensgefahr
wir gehen
wenn du auf eine kamera chef von oben
auf dem dach filmt und du siehst wie ein
tornado auf ein gebäude zusteuert ich
kann mir kaum vorstellen wie man sich da
fühlt
[Musik]
der tornado hat genau südlich des double
you tv-studios aufgesetzt
und dann hört das live gesendet er hat
auch absolut gemeistert
vielleicht sind wir gar nicht mehr auf
sendungen wir hoffen sie sind noch dran
der tornado hält direkt auf das studio
zu
alle sofort raus hier ab in den keller
sie haben entschieden sich selbst in
sicherheit zu bringen
die tonspur hält die beklemmenden moment
der evakuierung fest jd jetzt
er ist genau richtig gehandelt du willst
die öffentlichkeit informieren so lange
es geht aber wenn du selbst in gefahr
bist musst du dem zuschauer mit gutem
beispiel vorangehen
zum glück dreht der tornado rechtzeitig
nach süden ab der sender wird nicht
getroffen
aber andere teile der stadt werden
verwüstet ein mensch kommt ums leben
[Musik]
ist es gewohnt sich den naturgewalten zu
stellen wenn er von schweren unwettern
berichtet doch was macht er wenn ein
störenfried ins bild 9
januar 2014 ein wintersturm hat in süden
des landes zwischen texas und der küste
von north und south carolina lahmgelegt
er bringt schnee und eisregen canori
berichtet live aus charleston und
bekommt dort nicht nur vom wetter einen
stürmischen empfang
wir sind hier noch nicht in dem am
schlimmsten betroffenen teil dort werden
wir später noch hinfahren
jim ist ein profi er zögert keine
sekunde
er hat den zieht einfach abgeblockt ohne
die augen von der kamera zu nehmen das
zeigt dass er schon seit 20 jahren im
geschäft ist ich war schon ein paar mal
in charleston ich frage mich was sich
der typ dabei gedacht hat auch schinken
tory zuzulaufen ich meine jim ist ein
ganz schöner brecher mit so jemandem
liege ich mich doch nicht an
[Musik]
sehen sie gleich
sie hätten die producer und die toten
heute sehen sollen die standen da so
ich bin zurück zum wagen wo meine
twitter-nachrichten plötzlich
explodierte
am college von charleston herrscht
offenbar schon partystimmung das ist
eine der besten momente von jim carrey
ganz mister cool
manchmal ist das leben besser als jedes
drehbuch
[Musik]
nova scotia kanada ein eisiger nordost
sturm trifft die küste mit böen von 160
kilometer pro stunde und 60 zentimeter
schnee
wir wollen mit ihnen teilen was wir hier
erleben
zwei kanadische meteorologen gehen bei
ihrem live bericht an die grenzen ihrer
eigenen sicherheit ja es ist schon
erstaunlich wie sich schnee im wind
verändert wenn sand oder schnee mit 110
kilometer pro stunde auf dein gesicht
treffen ist dass wir einmal komplett
sandstrahlen
es fühlt sich an als ob man während
eines hurrikans am strand steht und der
sandhof geblasen werden
der wind ist so stark dass die reporter
sich kaum auf den beinen halten können
gewinnt heute nicht mehr er brüllt
nichts hört sich so an wie wind der mit
über 140 kilometer pro stunde
das typische pose des hurrikans zieht
mich besonders an es ist fast wie
infraschall
[Musik]
die zuschauer wissen nicht ob die
reporter sich verletzt haben
dies alles klar wieder zurück im bild
sehen sie vom sturz etwas mitgenommen
aus der windschutz fluss micro ist weg
in nordamerika heißen solche nordost
stürme noch ist es sind tiefdruckgebiete
die ihre kraft aus der relativ feucht
warmen luft über dem atlantik ziehe die
gefürchteten ozean winde wehen aus
nordöstlicher richtung
[Musik]
was wissen sie alles über schnee
das hängt von der dichte des schnees ab
im durchschnitt entspricht 1 zentimeter
regen zehn zentimetern schnee bei
pulverschnee können es mehr als doppelt
so viel sein
2008 bringt ein blitzer teilen der usa
und kanadas mehr als 60 zentimeter
neuschnee
der wintersturm ist gerade abgezogen als
der nachrichten reporter rock im
stadtpark von toronto über einen
schlauch reifen rodel rennen berichten
will
ich werde die zeit mit meiner stoppuhr
festhalten da kommen sie schon in hügel
runter hrubesch einzuführen
er konzentriert sich so sehr aufs rennen
das er ganz vergisst wo er steht
ruben führt und jetzt kommt's r und
ruben führt und jetzt kommt's l und
das hat ganz schön gerumpelt fast so aus
als hätten sie es auf ihn abgesehen
unglaublich wie schnell die sind
[Musik]
regel nummer eins wenn du über so eine
veranstaltung bericht ist stellt sicher
dass du nicht im weg steht ist mit
schlauchreifen ist die abfahrt nicht
steuerbar
das war eine schlechte idee vom
riverside park rock live global news er
hob das mikro auf und machte einfach
weiter
so läuft das in diesem geschäft manchmal
musst du einfach weitermachen
was wissen sie über die molekulare
struktur von schnee
[Musik]
richtig und falsch er stimmt das von der
molekül anordnung her keine schneeflocke
ist wie die andere aber sie alle folgen
35 speziellen formen diese entstehen
durch temperaturschwankungen in der
atmosphäre so formen sich die sechs arme
einer schneeflocke
darunter
ist bekannt für seine geistesgegenwart
selbst das schlimmste unwetter bringt
ihn nicht aus dem tritt aber manchmal
gibt es überraschende situationen auch
im studio wie hier im sommer 2014 bei
einer live sendung von nbc today und
jetzt hören wir wie das wetter wird der
rocker ist heute ausnahmsweise in
washington
ganz genau ich sollte ein interview mit
der frau des präsidenten führen und mein
sohn nick hatte geburtstag und
hier im westen wo ein großteil unseres
weizens angebaut wird rockers soll
außerhalb des bildes auf ihn warten doch
das geburtstagskind hat seinen eigenen
kopf es war so gegen halb neun bis dahin
hat er sich gut benommen doch dann
bemerkte ich wie ihr herum lief im
westen wo ein großteil unseres
wo ein großteil unseres weizens angebaut
wird
lässt sich nicht so einfach ausblenden
die temperaturen sind
überdurchschnittlich hoch
nicht hier sehen
kurz bevor sein kopf zu sehen ist merkt
man wie ich zur seite schaue ich ahnte
schon dass wir das machen würde
die temperaturen steigen es wird schüler
die windstärken liegen zwischen 30 und
50 km h schließlich gibt er auf örtlich
besteht brandgefahr
übrigens das ist mein sohn wer wird
heute 12 und leistet mir bei der arbeit
gesellschaft
und nicht erst
dachte ich du kleiner doch dann habe ich
nachgegeben eine perfekte video bombe
niki weiß wie es geht er heute ist er
der chef große klasse
genau er hat ja geburtstag
[Musik]
von der hauptstadt zu einem kleinen
lokalsender in phoenix arizona corrie
mccloskey von fox ten moderiert den
wetterbericht live doch die wetterkarte
hat anscheinend einen sonnenstich
und jetzt zu den temperaturen heute
band herrschen 400 grad celsius
und in aber toki sogar 690
ich habe zwar nicht das recht dazu aber
ich würde bei so einer hitze ja dringend
für eine evakuierung plädieren
die wetterkarte wird über ein
computerprogramm mit daten gefüttert da
muss wohl was schief gelaufen sein
kay kriegsfronten hills da sieht es auch
nicht besser aus und offen gesagt
wittenberg ist komplett verloren erst
kommt er ins stocken doch dann
überspielte es als er merkt dass noch
sechs weitere städte temperaturen über
700 grad haben steigt er einfach drauf
ein in surprise wird auch als bis zu 700
grad celsius in chandler und messer wird
es nicht so warm aber hier sollten sie
so schnell wie möglich verschwinden mehr
als 1600 grad ich glaube da schmilzt
sogar stahl cave queen müsste also schon
weg sein bei liveübertragungen musst du
als reporter oder sprecher innerhalb von
zehntelsekunden entscheiden was du tust
und er macht aus zitronenlimonade
[Musik]
wie heiß kann es in der resona
tatsächlich werden
die höchste temperatur die je in arizona
gemessen wurde waren sengende 53 grad am
lakers
[Musik]
aber den weltrekord hält das death
valley in kalifornien
dort stieg das quecksilber
1913 auf 56 grad
die meteorologen christi gordon ist ein
absoluter profi wenn es um die
wettermoderation geht aber im juni 2013
bringt sie eine schalte zur live kamera
auf dem dach des studios aus der fassung
kommt
es zu beträchtlichen niederschlag
diese ewige spinne krabbelt über das
objektiv es sieht aus als wäre sie
direkt über ihren kopf so
wirkt es für sie auf dem monitor
sie steht vor einem sogenannten green
screen auf die grüne fläche im
hintergrund wird das kamerabild gelegt
so wie hier hinter mir
die ist doch draußen wenn du lange vor
seinem green screen stehst hältst du es
für real und plötzlich taucht eine
riesige spinne auf
ein paar schrecksekunden später
schließlich reiste sich wieder zusammen
und moderiert zu ende ich mache dann mal
weiter alles kubach man da läuft es mir
kalt den rücken runter märz
die nächsten gefahren sind allerdings
real das hat diese ampel abgeknickt da
wünscht sich jeder hätte sich die diät
gespart auch wenn das nicht jede zu
begreifen scheint es ist echt
deprimierend das mit anzusehen
august 2011 hurrikan ireen nähert sich
der us-ostküste in den bundesstaaten die
auf seinem weg liegen leben 65 millionen
menschen ihnen drohen neben sturm auch
schwere überschwemmungen
jetzt kommt ein neues regenband der
meteorologe eric fischer berichtet live
aus virginia
er warnt vor den gefahren des sturms
doch nicht alle hören auf ihn
der verkehr läuft trotz der warnungen
weiter
es gibt einfach leute die ich verkneife
mir das lieber
das ist der alptraum jedes live reporter
ein paar jungs haben sich zu einem
spaziergang in badehose entschlossen
wir laufen einfach dutzende leute vorbei
es ist echt deprimierend dass zu sehen
in north carolina sind schon zwei
menschen ums leben gekommen einer starb
als er draußen nach seinen tieren sehen
wollte der andere kam beim autofahren um
manche leute machen sich einen spaß
draus dabei können tropenstürme richtig
gefährlich werden eine böe kann eine
große werbetafel umstürzen und dann
kriegen die leute die in badehose
rumspringen vielleicht ernsthafte
probleme
[Musik]
ich bin sprachlos wie viele leute
einfach weiter mit dem auto herumfahren
wurde auf der straße spazieren gehen ich
entschuldige mich für diesen anblick
sein bericht ging um die welt ich hoffe
er sieht rückblickend dass er das beste
aus der situation gemacht hat denn das
hat er
tatsächlich war hurrikan rina alles
andere als harmlos der sturm tötete in
den usa 45 menschen und verursachte
sachschaden von mehr als 15 milliarden
dollar er gilt als einer der
kostspieligsten stürme die jedi usa
getroffen haben
wissen sie wie viel regen bei einem
hurrikan herunterkommen
[Musik]
im schnitt bringt ein hurrikan täglich
rund eineinhalb zentimeter regen in
einem radius von rund 660 kilometern das
ergibt einen regen volumen von mehr als
20 millionen liter wasser damit lassen
sich über acht millionen wettkampf
schwimmbecken füllen
die wassermassen machen hurricanes neben
dem wind zu gefährlich aber auch ein
trockener wüstensturm ist nicht zu
unterschätzen wie marissa mayer im april
2011 feststellen muss bei ihrer
reportage aus dem kalifornischen palm
springs lässt sie sich nicht von den
staaten böden abhalten
kanns losgehen
ich liebe ihren ein stück sie reißt sich
zusammen setzt mein haar sitzt die kappe
ich kriege das hin
das ist ein heißer trockener wind dein
montag mit aus du weißt gar nicht mehr
was du sagen willst
ich weiß nicht es ist nicht lustig
sie will ihren bericht professionell
abliefern
der band es nur heftig
sie sagte dazu
so heftig im baum
gestürzt
nach zehn quälenden ticks versucht sie
es noch ein letztes mal
und der wird schließlich gesendet
[Musik]
palm springs ist für solche winde wie
geschaffen schließlich steht hier nicht
ohne grund einer der ältesten windparks
der usa wenn die hitze der wüste
aufsteigt entsteht ein tiefdruckgebiet
das kühle ozean luft anzieht auf seinem
weg durch die berge nimmt der wind fahrt
auf die bühne können so stark werden wie
ein hurrikan der niedrigsten kategorie 1
[Musik]
ein hurrikan der stufe 5 gehört zu den
heftigsten stürmen die es auf der welt
gibt sowie hurrikan wilma
oktober 2005 wilma baut sich über dem
atlantik auf und erreicht in böen fast
300 kilometer pro stunde die
zerstörungen reichen von mexiko bis
florida
[Musik]
von dort aus naples berichtet europa
live als der gefürchtete augen valdez
hurricanes auf die stadt trifft
wir bekommen gerade die rückseite des
augenblicks ab wir waren auf dem balkon
des ritz carlton es war also einer der
schicksten hackentricks für mich kein
schwenk runter damit europa nicht
umfällt hält ein techniker einfach seine
beine fest der sturm ist brutal wenn man
sieht wie die bäume im hintergrund hin
und her peitschen wird einem klar in was
für einen sturm r da steht
die bäume biegen sich links und rechts
es ist unglaublich
bei so einem wind fliegen auch trümmer
durch die luft wie geschosse da kann
alles passieren
unser techniker tom hat mir gerade
gesagt jetzt wünscht du dir du hättest
auf die diät verzichtet
alles klar uns geht's gut
alles gut wir kommen rein
der wind muss ganz schön stark sein um
einen mann umzuhauen egal wie groß er
ist ich gehe jetzt
erst will man lachen aber gleichzeitig
merkt man wie ernst die sache ist
ein brenzlige augenblick man merkt
plötzlich wie stark dieser sturm ist und
dass man überhaupt keine kontrolle mehr
hat ich muss
zerstörungskraft war gigantisch in
mexiko der karibik und den usa kamen
durch den sturm und seine folgen 62
menschen ums leben wenn zuschauer einen
reporter mitten aus einem hurrikan
berichten sehen fragen sie sich was soll
das aber die leute die dort leben wollen
wissen was da los ist die wellen sind
bis zu vier meter hoch
eigentlich geht es darum den leuten zu
sagen macht es nicht wie wir mit unserem
service wollen wir den leuten klarmachen
haltet euch lieber nicht hierauf wir
zeigen euch wie gefährlich es draußen
ist bleibt schön zu hause